what's up everyone welcome back to the
clatter interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 I am sitting next to Robert
Morgan the director of stop motion huge
congratulations on this movie it is a
major feed in a number of respects thank
you very much so clearly I like your
movie a lot of our viewers will not know
about stop motion just yet and they'll
be learning about it through the
Festival so would you mind giving a
brief synopsis of your film to start
yeah stop motion is a uh a psychological
horror film about a stop motion animator
played by Ashley franos
who I don't know how much to give away
who this is part of the reason why I
like synopsis CU then they tell me when
to stop yeah uh who who starts to make a
film
under Psy some psychological stress and
bad things happen yeah okay that's
that's spot on there so I wanted to
start with two personal questions for
you B based on how you described the
movie in your director's statement so as
a filmmaker can you give us an example
of a time when you went too far with
your art where you kind of had to check
yourself and put yourself back into
perspective but then I want the opposite
a time when you went above and beyond
and I don't know maybe prove naysayers
wrong and how and up to the confidence
you had in yourself as a filmmaker I
mean to answer both those questions I
would I would talk about a spe one
specific film that I made a short
animation film I made called Bobby year
which was made about 10 years ago I
think it played here actually a
fantastic Fest and that film took I mean
I made that film with no money over a
period of about 3 years just sort of
semi- improvising it um making
everything myself and um um and it it
became a an almost sort of sick
Obsession and actually the the the film
here stop motion uh is inspired by my
making of that film because I had the
Sensation that the film started to take
on a life of its own and uh that was
kind of part of the inspiration for for
this movie stop motion and um and I
think I just got really immersed and
sort of sort of drowned in it a little
bit and I actually got so obsessed with
it I actually got ill I got pneumonia
while I was making it because I I I kind
of was pushing myself too hard and
making myself sick from just the the
sheer Obsession and stress of getting it
perfect so that was a part a period of
going too far like it did have a almost
like a physical sort of physically
assaulted by your own film um and uh
what was the other then the opposite
like a t a time when you kind of prove
naysayers Wrong by going above and
beyond and pushing yourself F farther
than you ever could have imagined well
this it's the same film because it was
uh a film that uh yeah I mean it was it
was a complete kind of work of obsession
when I finished it it was about 23
minutes long bad bad length for a
festival for festivals for a short film
that's like most people told me cut it
down it's too long for festivals just
cut it down I was like I'm not cutting
it down I'm not touching it I don't care
if festivals don't like it that is the
film and I started sending it to
festivals and the first couple of
festivals I sent it to rejected it and I
was like oh that's maybe I should have
listened but no I I don't care I I love
the length it is and then it started
picking up and going to more festivals
and then it just became this absolute
sort of phenomenally successful Festival
film it played at Sundance it won 30
Awards
and and and and off the back of that I
met uh Alan the producer of of um of
stop motion and Wild Bunch and those
guys because they were fans of the short
and this led to this film yeah it's the
best thing about film festivals you you
start to connect those dots and you
never know when someone's going to help
you get another project off the ground
great it's the best thing in the world
all right I want to talk about oh
actually before that short is on your
YouTube channel like if someone wants to
go out and watch it they could look up
Robert Morgan on YouTube and quickly
find that yeah all of my short films are
on recommend if you haven't seen it yet
so I want to talk a little bit about the
art of stop motion which again
fascinates me to no end I have great
respect for anybody who could power
through the amount of effort time energy
everything that it takes to make a film
like that first let's say there's
someone out there who really wants to
try stop motion animation for the very
first time what is one key piece of
advice you would give them in order to
get them started on the right foot get
yourself uh a
laptop get yourself a cheap digital SLR
camera get yourself Dragon frame or or
or or there are other uh stop motion
animation uh softwares on the market um
but get get yourself a little setup
basically and and get yourself a setup
that you can do from home and start
experimenting because it's only by doing
it I I don't think you could you could
possibly um sort of uh prepare somebody
for stop motion you have to just do it
and then you'll know very quickly
whether you have an affinity with it or
not um some people do some people don't
you know I teach animation as well and
some students have it some don't and
actually when we were when when when I
was doing stop motion I had to teach
Ashling franos the ACT I have many
questions about that okay I had to teach
her how to animate I had to show her the
ropes and uh her F she is basically an
amazing animator so so her first attempt
at animating she was just doing it and
she was like it's actually pretty pretty
excellent animation for somebody who's
literally never done it before that is
not an easy thing to do because it's not
like you can just have an actor in this
movie who could kind of like go through
the motions and repeat things she needs
to make sure that the audience believes
that that Artistry has been in her
family since she was born so having that
kind of level of understanding is
absolutely key to this film working what
is something about her and how she
picked up stop motion animation that
signal to you that she is one of those
people who just got it who had it in her
I knew I knew from the first moment I
spoke to her in fact I knew I mean you
know we had a there was a list of actors
that that could have played this role
and uh I had a very small small list I
think there were only a handful who I
really felt could do and Ashley was one
of those actors and so uh yeah she
responded to the script loved it uh we
chatted on zoom and you know straight
away I just thought this is just you
know she said straight away she wanted
to do it and then we could just sort of
relax and talk about the character she
was already the cogs were already
turning she was already talking about
how she was going to do certain things
on our first meeting you know so I just
knew straight away this is someone who's
very very serious and committed and uh
she's a chameleon as well if you watch
her film she's different in everything
she does so I knew she would you know
totally bury herself and immerse herself
into the role and so I I I didn't really
worry about it at all I kind of knew it
was just it was in excellent hands and I
think it's I think I was right you know
yeah oh my God definitely she's
definitely one of those actors who I I
have uh Full Faith Can Do absolutely
anything so you cast her in the role you
have that faith in her can you maybe
give an example of something happened
during the making of the movie where she
took something well beyond what you ever
could have imagined where maybe she
brought something out of your own
screenplay that you didn't even realize
was there to begin
with um I think it
was in in every facet of the character's
uh emotional Journey she
communicated all of those PL emotional
places more than I thought those
emotional places would be expressed so
the sense of kind of sadness within her
came across more strong more strongly
the sense of obsession came across more
strongly and the sense of Rage came
across more more strongly as well like
without giving anything away you know
but there was there are there are images
of her rage in this which are which are
quite terrifying uh and she's so she's
so um you know I think one one of the
things I really like about her
performance is there's a really broad
range of of of places she goes to she's
actually really sweet in some scenes and
vulnerable and then in other scenes
she's quite cruel and in other scene
she's just terrifying and um and I think
and she's sweet when she talks to the
the little girl kin she's really she's
very maternal as well and very kind of
uh sort of sweet with her so I think
there's a just a really nice range of of
of emotions that she plays what was it
like casting the little girl role
because that see that seems like an
especially challenging uh part for a
young actor to take on and it seemed
like the two of them wound up making the
perfect pairing together yeah I mean I
don't want to just make out it was all a
breeze but I mean it
was you know kayn's amazing she's just
such an amazing actor and such a
professional in fact the first time we
did a little um rehearsal I wanted to
just get uh kayin and Ashling together
to just play out a little scene just to
see what it would be like and at the end
of it ashleen said to me I've I've got
to up my game cuz she's like really good
and um yeah she's a complete natural but
she was um she was in uh that George
Clooney movie in the midnight sky
midnight sky yes so and and I'd read up
about how you know Clooney had searched
for a long time for the right girl and
he he looked at hundreds and hundreds of
uh Child Actors and and singled kin out
so I just thought well that's he's done
all my work for
me than Georgey but um yeah I think
she's brilliant oh yeah you know the two
of them are absolutely perfect together
I wanted to go back to some of my stop
motion questions here especially because
you know I I do think a lot of aspiring
filmmakers tend to watch collider
they're always looking for inspiration
and advice what would you say is the
biggest misconception about what it
means to be a stop motion animator
biggest
misconception well ironically because
I'm guilty of this cuz I've just made a
film about a very weird uh and uh scary
animator is the the misconceptions that
we're all weird and scary cuz we're not
um although you wouldn't think that from
watching you know this film you mean
that's that is a fair example to bring
up right there whether it's something in
this film or all the shorts you've
animated what is the what is the single
most difficult thing to bring to life
via stop motion uh walking really yeah
characters
walking I mean there's nothing I hate
more when I'm animating is having to
animate a character walk into a room in
a big wide shot so I try and avoid it as
much as possible it's just you've got so
you've got so it's so boring and you've
got and it's not really about act the
the performance of the character it's
just sort of administrative boring stuff
of getting a character from A to B but
you got to do all this annoying leg work
and arm movements and stuff and I just
find it really boring so I tend not to
do it anymore um when I have a
character's walking into a room I just
cut to a closeup and slide it off screen
you can I get it cuz yeah you just use I
just use editing to get around it cuz I
can't be bothered anymore I am curious
about the uh production process on this
film is it a situation where you film
all the liveaction components and then
take your time working on the stop
motion elements but I would also imagine
that you need your puppets beforehand so
that the actors that are doing the live
action material could be Hands-On and it
could flow together well so what's the
timeline on something like this the the
the the the animation characters the
puppets were yeah they are props as well
as characters that that that are in the
film and come to life and stuff so they
have to be props that the actors could
handle so they had to they were all
working puppets so we made we basically
we made all of the puppets before we
shot and then we shot all of the live
action stuff and then uh there were the
scenes where that the animation uh shoot
was sort of um in two phases the first
phase is where there's any um animation
puppets interacting with live action
characters in the same frame so for
example there's a scene where ashling's
in bed and a car one of the puppets
walks into the room and um that had to
be shot at the same time as the live
action stuff because we because you know
it has to be the plates have to be have
to match very technical boring stuff
that I won't go into but it had to be
done parallel to the to the live action
shoot when all of that was done and all
the stuff involving the actors was done
we started editing and while editing I
went and shot all of the film within the
film stuff uh using the puppets that had
been props they're now puppets and then
I animated that stuff and I'm and I have
the benefit of watching a cut forming at
the same time so I can sort of M tailor
the animation a little bit to how it
cuts in and out of it CU cuz we're
already getting the you know I'm editing
the film at the same time so can you
maybe give us a specific example of that
a time when some of the liveaction
material you shot wound up influencing
what you animated after the fact yeah so
in the in the one of the this one of the
animation sequences that she does when
we first meet this this this Ashman
character brilliant character brilliant
character so that so the the scene when
when she comes out of that bit of
Animation starts with a shot of the
window from inside the set and the
puppet standing outside the set and she
picks it up and says what should we call
this guy and then they talk about it
well when I animated I thought well I'm
going to end the sequence with the same
frame as what we've edit what we shot in
live action so the animation sequence
ends with the Ashman character walking
towards the window and ending in that
same frame so it cuts really well that
because I've because I've sort of used
the live action footage to actually
inform how I approached the uh the
animation footage if that makes sense
yes it does many moving Parts here again
this it very yeah very comp it's a feet
as though shooting a liveaction film
alone isn't Tough Enough and as though
shooting a stop motion animation film
alone isn't tough enough now you're
combining them and the techniques
techniques pair together
Rel relatively low budget as well my my
brain seriously can't process that um
you brought up the ash man so I'll go
I'll go to him next what would you say
is the biggest difference between how
you picture that character looking when
you first conceived of him and then how
he turns out in the finished film that's
a good question cuz I when we wrote the
script um the the character is made out
of like raw meat and dirt and and other
stuff and that could go so many places
but I think there was a certain I think
what CU there there are there are
various iteration that's what made it
even more complex is there are various
iterations of that character without
giving anything away the Ashman has
different forms in the film and so
they're all quite different versions of
it but they all you all have to you
always have to know it's the same
character so there has to be certain
signifiers within the within the design
of the character that that tell you it's
the same character in a different form
this won't make sense to you watching
this but when you watch the filmm oh it
will that it'll make all the sense it'll
make sense when you watch the film um
and for me it was the it was trying to
kind of identify an a facial expression
that was just sort of quite um intense
and scary and keep that consistent so it
came down to the eyes basically like
focusing on the eyes so that was always
consistent when we wrote the script it
mentions in the script it has the
staring eyes so that was the thing that
kind of but yeah it it the Pres the
presence of the ash man is more
important than how it looks so I was
never that obsessed with how it looks it
was more about the feeling it creates
and you don't see it that clearly it
sort of you know you see glimpses of it
but it's not that clear feel like you
should do this is my big promotional
idea you could tell IFC about this
hopefully they watch this you should
make to promote the movie some sort of
uh like a a 101 video like create your
own Ashman I would I would take that
kind of tutorial I'm trying to make one
myself yeah really um speaking of that
actually whether it's something in this
film or anything else you've made what
is like the most bizarre material you've
ever used to create a character or a set
oh that's easy I Ed my toenails once to
make a puppet out of it's in this this
film go check out Bobby a on YouTube
because it's got um a puppet made of
about a Year's worth of my toenails oh
no did you did you deliberately make
that choice at the top of a year that I
am going to collect enough to make to
make this thing in my next short no I I
I just started collecting my toenails
and uh I didn't know what for I just
thought oh I I quite like collecting my
toenails putting them in a little bottle
and then when I was making Bob a I
thought oh that would make quite
interesting material to make a pop out
of so that's why I did do you have like
a white whale kind of material like a
material out there that interests you
that you're hoping to make a character
out of one day I mean you can make a
character out of anything literally you
know so there's nothing specific but you
you could I mean if you can touch it you
can animate
it the possibilities in my head that are
swirling right now wanted to make sure
to squeeze in this question before we
have to wrap up cuz someone I forget who
it was someone at this Festival
described your movie to me as squelchy
because of the visuals and in particular
the sound design so I did want to ask
you about finding the right sounds here
and I watched a couple of your shorts it
does seem like there are similarities so
maybe what kind of sound techniques have
you used in the past that came in handy
here but maybe what are some new sound
design elements that you Incorporated in
stop motion for the first time um yeah I
mean I I uh I think sound is vitally
important for films like this but also
um you know a film that envelops you
like this or int that's the intention
anyway so sound is for me 50% of the
experience I it's that important I think
it really does help you know immerse the
viewer into the into the world of the
film so I've always been very obsessed
with um having a lot of attention to
detail with the sound so all the Foley
is extremely detailed so when puppets
move the clothes you hear the clothes
moving and there is you know the they
they they are a little bit sweaty and
sticky looking so it just makes sense
that they make that kind of noise when
they move um and then with this film I I
work with an amazing sound designer
based in London called Ben bed who who
uh just did an amazing job and kept the
consistency of the sort of thing I've
done in my shorts but he's he's taken it
to another level so it has that um
intensity of Foley in it but also he
bought in new things it was his idea for
example to bring in the squeaking sound
of the arm
that was his idea and he he just said
that would be quite an interesting thing
to play with and actually as as as we
went further into the sound editing of
the film that became more and more
useful there are that sound crops up in
in inappropriate moments shall we
say um good teas right there yeah so and
that was an that was a really really
exciting uh thing that he came up with
that allowed us to really kind of bring
the concepts home more clearly that just
how lost in the world of Animation the
Ella actually is this is a like a really
big broad question here a question that
might be tough to answer but again I
can't emphasize this enough what you've
done here is a film making feat so I'm
curious do you have any goals for
yourself as a filmmaker that maybe feel
more Within Reach now than ever because
you accomplished that motion because
this movie existed and you did it I mean
every film's difficult you know it's
they have different every filmm has
different challenges the the good thing
about doing a film like this is if you
can pull it off it has a builtin sort of
wow factor because it is doing something
quite novel with animation and and live
action not that you should let that uh
you should be complacent about the other
aspects you have to be totally full-on
you know making sure every single aspect
of the film is is working but it gives
you a bit of a safety net so in a way
not it's not a safety net but it's like
it gives you a sort of secret weapon in
a way that you've you know um if if if
if there are other problems in the film
you have this this element that I I was
fairly certain was going to work but I
think you know I wasn't complacent I
worked very hard to make sure all of the
elements were working but you know if
you take that away then you like for
example I would say it's much more
difficult it would be for me at least to
strip all of that stuff away and just
have a film that's only about
performance and acting and you know um
so it's not necessarily easier to make a
simpler kind of film you know it can it
can work both ways I think all films are
very difficult to make oh my God yeah I
I think all films like literally every
single movie that is made is like kind
of a miracle and it deserves to be
applauded yeah definitely yeah yeah it's
incredibly difficult to get not even
before you even get to the set to
actually get it financed and it's hu you
know huge respect to anyone who just
gets a film made and every step of the
process it never gets any easier uh
speaking of that this is my first
fantastic Fest one of my favorite things
about being here is just seeing so many
wonderful filmmakers support each other
be excited for each other and be
inspired by each other as well so can
you pinpoint something you've seen in
another film here that made you go like
damn that is impressive and that
inspires me I really enjoyed
infested which was the kind of the
killer spider movie I'm I'm a bit
screamish about spiders not quite an ARA
arachnophobe but I thought it was a
really nice mix of sort of social
commentary mixed with just like killer
spiders and some of the scenes in it uh
the way that they were staged with with
you know the audience seeing the spiders
and the and the characters not seeing
not seeing the spiders was incredibly
well done and it just you could hear the
you could hear the sort of um the the
visceral reaction I mean it really helps
because it's spiders because spiders are
just it's just they're just inherently
just horrible and I I was very impressed
as well with the I'm assuming it was CG
that they did the SP you know but it's
they pulled it off really well I think
it really does it normally that kind of
thing would be very difficult to pull
off CG spiders but I think it it I'm
assuming it was a mixture of practical
and CG but it worked very well I think I
it never took me out of the film it
really felt like they were in the room I
love hearing that yeah do you think you
could ever bring yourself to stop motion
animate a
spider no that's where I draw the line I
feel like I just gave you a challenge
though and you should try to that
challeng that's just
evil I I would be I I I am actually
quite squeamish about spiders okay okay
I mean you make people squeamish with
just about everything else in your
animated work in this film Stop Motion
is incredible again huge congratulations
to Youk much to everybody out there one
keep an eye out for stop motion again is
a phenomenal film but in the meantime
while you're waiting to see it do check
out Robert's YouTube channel because his
shorts are there they are all
exceptional we'll see you soon at
Fantastic f for more
interviews